THAT ON MY RADIO SHOW, SO I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE GET THE
FACTS FOR OUR AUDIENCE.
TO THINK AS ALWAYS.
NOW WE TURN OUR FOCUS BACK TO
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THE SWAMP, WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS ISSUED A STERN WARNING FOR
ANYONE ATTEMPTING TO VANDALIZE
HISTORIC MONUMENTS AND
BUILDINGS.
YESTERDAY, HE VOWED TO ENFORCE
THE PRESERVATION ACT AND PUT ANY
VANDALS BEHIND BARS FOR UP TO
TEN YEARS.
TODAY DURING A SPEECH IN
ARIZONA, JUST A COUPLE OF SHORT
HOURS AGO, THE PRESIDENT HAD
THIS TO SAY ABOUT SOME OF THE
FAR LEFT PROTESTERS CAUSING
MASSIVE UNREST IN AMERICA’S
CITIES.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY ARE TEARING DOWN
STATUES, DESECRATING MONUMENTS,
AND PURGING DISSENTERS.
IS NOT THE BEHAVIOR OF A
PEACEFUL POLITICAL MOVEMENT.
IS THE BEHAVIOR OF TOTALITARIANS
AND TYRANTS AND PEOPLE THAT
DON’T LOVE OUR COUNTRY.
THEY DON’T LOVE OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THIS COMES AS
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN D.C. FACED
ANOTHER WAVE OF ANGRY
PROTESTERS.
TONIGHT, POLICE ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY CONTINUE TO NOW FACE
HORRIFIC CONDITIONS NOW HEADING
UP TO 900 INJURED, ROCKS,
BOTTLES, BRICKS, MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS, AS MANY OF SIX, JUST
A SMALL SAMPLE OF WHAT THEY ARE
UP AGAINST.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU ARE A PIECE OF BELIEF.
YOU REALLY ARE.
YOU ARE PART OF THE PROBLEM.
>> Sean: AS YOU CAN SEE, NOT
EXACTLY THE EASIEST JOB IN THE
WORLD.
DESPITE WHAT OUR EXTREME
CONDITIONS POLICE ARE FACING,
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS ARE
LEAVING THEM OUT TO DRY, SOME
EVEN CALLING FOR THE ENTIRE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS IN BIG CITIES
TO BE DEFUNDED AND EVEN
DISMANTLED.
NOW, THESE ARE THE SAME
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS AS WE
WENT OVER IN GREAT DETAIL LAST
NIGHT AND WON’T REITERATE
TONIGHT BUT TO SUM UP, HAVE
FAILED THEIR CITIES FOR DECADES.
THEIR EDUCATION SYSTEM IN RUINS.
HAS BEEN OUT OF CONTROL FOR
DECADES.
THEY DON’T SOLVE OR FIX ANY
PROBLEM.
SAFETY AND SECURITY FOR EVERY
AMERICAN SHOULD BE A PROTECTED
RIGHT.
IN THE PAST FEW WEEKS, A WAVE OF
LOOTING, ARSON, VANDALISM,
PRECINCT BURNING, PRECINCTS
TAKEN OVER AND ERECT CITY
CENTERS.
SO WHAT DOES THE DEMOCRATIC
PRESUMPTIVE NOMINEE’S PLAN TO
RESTORE ORDER IN AMERICA’S
LIBERAL STUDIES AS WE BEGIN OUR
OPENING MONOLOGUE TONIGHT.
AFTER ALL, WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
CANDIDATE.
IS 133 DAYS UNTIL WE WILL HAVE
THE ULTIMATE DECISION.
THE ULTIMATE JERRY.
WHILE THE EVER WEAK AND
FORGETFUL JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN
PUBLIC LIFE ARE OVER 50 YEARS,
SO OVER FIVE DECADES, HE MUST
HAVE COME UP WITH A PLAN AND
MUST HAVE DONE THINGS, RIGHT?
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA WILL NEVER
TELL YOU.
WE MIGHT NEVER KNOW BECAUSE THE
FORGETFUL ONE HAS NOT HELD A
PRESS CONFERENCE AND 82 DAYS.
THE MEDIA MOB OF COURSE AIDING
AND ABETTING AND PROTECTING
FRAGILE JOE JUST LIKE THEY DID
HILLARY IN 2016.
AFTER 82 DAYS, JOE HAS BEEN
MOSTLY HIDING IN HIS BASEMENT
BUNKER.
THAT PLEASES TERRY McCULLOUGH,
I’M FINE WITH HIM IN THE
BASEMENT, HE ONLY SEES TWO
PEOPLE A DAY.
HE’S GOING TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
AND WE ARE GOING TO VOTE IN 133
DAYS?
PRETTY MUCH HE HAS ALL BUT SHUT
OFF FROM THE OUTSIDE WORLD, NOT
WEIGHING IN ON THE BIG ISSUES OF
THE DAY INSTEAD OF TAKING ANY
QUESTIONS FROM REPORTERS, HE
CONDUCTS WHAT ARE THESE
PRESCRIPTED AND FRANKLY PATHETIC
PODCASTS WHICH HE SOMEHOW
MANAGES TO EVEN BOTCH AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
NO OUTRAGE FROM THE MEDIA MOB,
HE GETS A PASS.
PREDICTABLY, THEY DO THIS OFTEN.
HE GOES A FEW SECONDS OR DAYS
WITHOUT TAKING QUESTIONS, THEY
HAVE A COLLECTIVE MELTDOWN.
JOE BIDEN CAN ACTUALLY GO 82
DAYS WITH NO QUESTIONS, NO MEDIA
PRETTY MUCH AT ALL, ONLY
FRIENDLY MEDIA?
THAT’S BECAUSE THEY ARE
SHIELDING JOE BIDEN, THEY KNOW
IT BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
ISSUE POLICE REFORM GUIDELINES.
NOW, JOE WAS VICE PRESIDENT
EIGHT YEARS AND HE NEVER DID
THAT.
BY THE WAY, WE NOW KNOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE ONE THAT
PASSED CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
PRISON REFORM.
THAT WASN’T BARACK AND IT WASN’T
JOE.
IN FACT, SENATE DEMOCRATS ARE
NOW STALLING REFORM EFFORTS IN
THE SENATE TONIGHT AS WE SPEAK.
THEY KNOW IT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP
ALSO.
HE’S THE ONE THAT EXPANDED
FUNDING AND COMMITMENT,
UNPRECEDENTED COMMITMENT FOR
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES IN
AMERICA.
WASN’T JOE BIDEN AND IT WASN’T
BARACK OBAMA AND HE CREATED
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND
STRUGGLING NEIGHBORHOODS.
HE TALKED ABOUT ALL OF THIS IN
HIS SPEECH TONIGHT.
WASN’T BARACK AND IT WASN’T JOE.
AND JOE AGAIN FIVE DECADES IN
GOVERNMENT.
TRUMP, LESS THAN FOUR YEARS.
OF COURSE, THE MEDIA MOB ALSO
VERY WORRIED THAT BIDEN CAN’T
ACTUALLY ANSWER TOUGH QUESTIONS
AT ALL.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE KNOW TODAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS VOWING TO
LOCK UP ANYBODY WHO VANDALIZE
HIS OUR HISTORIC MONUMENTS AND
BUILDINGS.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE HAS A
POSITION.
HE HAS TAKEN A STAND.
SO THE QUESTION THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA IF THEY HAD HALF A SENSE
TO DO THEIR JOB, THEY WOULD
INSIST ON THESE ANSWERS TONIGHT.
WHAT WOULD JOE DO?
WHAT WOULD BIDEN DO?
DOES HE SUPPORT THE TEARING DOWN
OF STATUES?
OF MONUMENTS?
WHAT ABOUT THE MONUMENTS IN
BALTIMORE BY NANCY PELOSI’S
FATHER AND KEPT IN PLACE BY HER
OWN BROTHER?
SO TONIGHT, WE ASK OKAY, DEZ
JOE BIDEN EVER SUPPORT THE
VANDALISM FOR EXAMPLE THAT TOOK
PLACE LAST NIGHT AT ST. JOHN’S
CHURCH WITH BLACK HOUSE HOUSE
AUTONOMOUS ZONE SPRAY-PAINTED ON
THE FRONT OF THAT CHURCH.
A FAR LEFT ACTIVIST JOHN KING,
NOW HE WANTS AND IS LEADING AN
EFFORT APPARENTLY FOR STATUES OF
JESUS TORN DOWN BECAUSE HE
THINKS THEY ARE "A FORM OF WHITE
SUPREMACY.
OKAY.
JOE BIDEN, THE FORGETFUL ONE, DO
YOU AGREE OR DISAGREE?
AND JOE, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
SEATTLE’S LAWLESS CHAZ, CHOP,
SUMMER OF LOVE FESTIVAL ZONE AND
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY TO THE
PEOPLE WHOSE BUSINESSES IN
SEATTLE HAVE NOW BEEN DESTROYED
IN THOSE SIX BLOCKS OF
LAWLESSNESS?
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY TO THE
900 OR SO POLICE OFFICERS THAT
WERE INJURED WITH ROCKS AND
BOTTLES AND BRICKS AND MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS?
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE FAMILIES
THAT LOST LOVED ONES FOR SERVING
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND PROTECTING
THEM AS POLICE OFFICERS?
DO YOU SUPPORT JOE, THE SEATTLE
MAYOR, DO YOU TO SUPPORT THE
WASHINGTON STATE GOVERNOR, DO
YOU SUPPORT ALLOWING A LARGE
PART OF AN AMERICAN CITY TO BE
TAKEN OVER?
IF YOU DO, LET US KNOW.
YOU DON’T, TELL US WHAT YOUR
SOLUTIONS ARE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SOLUTIONS FOR
POLICE AND COMMUNITY RELATIONS.
WHY DID YOU AND BARACK IMPLEMENT
CHANGES TO MECCA AFTER
CAMBRIDGE, AFTER FERGUSON, AFTER
BALTIMORE AND AT ANY POINT IN
THE EIGHT YEARS YOU AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHY DIDN’T YOU DO
IT THEN >> Sandra: AS WE
CONTINUE OUR QUESTIONING, WHAT
WITH THE EVER WHAT HAVE YOU DONE
IN THE LAST 50 YEARS?
THAT’S A LEGITIMATE QUESTION.
AND JOE BY THE WAY, REMEMBER, WE
HAVEN’T FORGOTTEN, YOU FOUGHT
AGAINST INTEGRATION EFFORTS
ALONGSIDE LEADING
SEGREGATIONISTS.
BY THE WAY, HERE’S A QUESTION
FOR JOE, DO YOU REGRET THAT?
DO YOU REGRET OPENLY WORRYING
THAT YOUR KIDS COULD GROW UP IN
A RACIAL JUNGLE, YOUR WORDS.
DO YOU REGRET AUTHORING THE 1994
CRIME BILL, THAT’S THE ONE THAT
LED TO MASS INCARCERATION OF
MINORITIES IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE ONE WITH
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM THAT
DONALD TRUMP FIXED AND BY THE
WAY, DO YOU REGRET PRAISING THE
FORMER GRAND BAH OF THE
KU KLUX KLAN BECAUSE YOU PRAISED
HIM A LOT.
ALSO, CONGRESSWOMAN CAUSEY OF
CORTEZ ADVISING THE CAMPAIGN.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THE SOCIALIST
UTOPIAN VISION?
YOU SAID YOU SUPPORT A GREEN NEW
DEAL, DO YOU SUPPORT HER VERSION
OF A GREAT NEW DEAL, AND GOING
TO GIVE EVERYTHING AWAY FREELY.
AND WHEN YOU GOING TO REPLACE
THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD’S
ECONOMY, BUT START THAT QUESTION
FOR JOE.
AND WILL YOU ENCOURAGE
BUSINESSES TO MOVE OUT OF CHINA?
ARE YOU GOING TO HOLD CHINA’S
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE EVEN
THOUGH YOUR SON, ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER GOT A BETTER DEAL THAN HE
GOT IN TERMS OF UKRAINE.
AND WITH CHINA, YOU’VE GOT A
SWEETHEART $1.5 BILLION DEAL
WITH THE ACTUAL BANK OF CHINA
AND WE DON’T SEE ANY EXPERIENCE
IN HIS BACKGROUND AT ALL THAT
WOULD’VE WARRANTED SUCH A DEAL
BUT IT HAPPENED SHORTLY AFTER HE
STEPPED OFF YOUR AIR FORCE TO
AIRPLANE IN BEIJING WHEN YOU
WENT TO VISIT ASIA AND CHINA.
ANOTHER QUESTION IS WILL YOU ASK
YOUR SON TO GIVE UP THE SHARES
AND THE INVESTMENT OF THAT
$1.5 BILLION DEAL WITH CHINA OR
MAYBE GIVE BACK THE MONEY FROM
BURISMA HOLDINGS THAT HE ADMITS
HE HAS ZERO EXPERIENCE IN AND
GOT PAID ANYWAY?
I DON’T KNOW, I HAVE NO IDEA.
NO EXPERIENCE, NONE, WHATSOEVER.
THAT’S A LOT OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, AND YOU DID THREATEN TO
FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR.
I’D LIKE TO KNOW YOUR ANSWER.
WHY WOULD YOU LEVERAGE THE
QUID PRO QUO OF BILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
WE ALSO KNOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
CHINA TRAVEL BAN WENT INTO
EFFECT TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED CONFIRMED CASE OF
CORONAVIRUS IN THE U.S.
JOE, YOU CALLED A HYSTERICAL,
XENOPHOBIC, AND FEARMONGERING.
OKAY, WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY?
TWO MONTHS IN THREE DAYS LATER,
YOU SAID YOU DID SUPPORT THE
TRAVEL BAN.
AT THAT TIME, IT WAS WAY TOO
LATE.
WE CAN GO ON AND ON.
LET’S END WITH ONE MORE
IMPORTANT QUESTION.
HERE’S A QUESTION WE NEED TO ASK
OURSELVES IS A COUNTRY IN 133
DAYS.
DOES THE EVER FRAIL, FORGETFUL
78-YEAR-OLD CONFUSED AND
CONFOUNDED JOE BIDEN, DOES HE
HAVE THE STRENGTH, DOES HE HAVE
THE STAMINA, DOES HE HAVE THE
ALERTNESS, THE MENTAL ACUITY TO
PERFORM THE TOUGHEST JOB IN THE
WORLD WELL INTO HIS 80s?
THE MEDIA MIGHT WANT TO ASK THE
AGE QUESTIONS THAT THEY HAD NO
TROUBLE ASKING RONALD REAGAN IN
1984.
WE GET TO SEE ALL OF THE MEDICAL
RECORDS.
WHERE THEY EVEN BOTHERED TO
PRESSURE THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN TO
HOLD A SIMPLE PRESS CONFERENCE?
LET’S START WITH A ZOOM PRESS
CONFERENCE.
I WOULD ARGUE TONIGHT 133 DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE TO SEE
JOE BIDEN.
JOE COME OUT OF HIDING AND TELL
US WHERE YOU STAND.
TELL US WHY YOU DIDN’T DO MORE
IN 50 YEARS IN PUBLIC LIFE.
YOU ARE ONE TEAM, THE MOB AND
THE MEDIA PROTECTING YOU, BUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, I GIVE THEM
A LOT OF CREDIT.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO SEE
THROUGH THIS CHARADE AND AGAIN,